this morning we learn this review by
inventing new idea that not only can we
think of complex numbers as tweets which
is crazy enough but if they're put in a
2d space now we don't just need to think
about them or we're not just limited to
thinking about that in terms of
horizontal vertical we can also talk
about them in terms of their distance
from the origin and the angle they form
with the positive real axis so that was
the modulus and the argument
respectively thank you so we have a new
way of writing out complex numbers now
to help you understand why this is not
just an oddity like oh okay that's cool
you can do it like this if you want to
write why is it actually really really
valuable
they're dumb and elegant okay I want us
to go back to this we looked at this a
little while ago we were first trying to
wrap our heads around one does
multiplication mean in the context of
complex numbers right and so what we
determined was based on this example
where we started is that it was oh
there's multiplication of equally
rotation okay now what I want us to do
is to try and think about this what yes
I lost like 90% of my anyway I want us
to take this old example and just look
through it with the lens of modules are
you informed to see what kinds of
insights it will yield for us okay so
let's just quickly your house if we
start with z1 being right here on the
real axis okay let's do the
multiplication again and get our for our
four points okay so is m2 if I multiply
by I 1 times I is just just one load
behind
Wow it's that late on a Friday afternoon
okay it's just I multiply is z2 by I
again and that gives you negative one so
that's every Kia that's purely real sore
back on the real axis and then our last
time if you go multiply by I one more
that's when you get negative fine okay
all right now we know this in terms of
this is only a Cartesian form as it were
X plus iy let's get it let's read off
what these points are in terms of
modulus and argument okay let's start
with z1 is everyone is equal to now
because these are all the same distance
right the modulus for this particular
example is very easy
what's the modulus what it's just one
like distance from the origin which in
this case is just one so I'm just gonna
write down the one even though it's
slightly redundant why don't we walk up
foot twist later and then what comes in
the brackets what corresponds to X plus
iy I'm going to put my trig functions
right it'll be cos theta plus I sine
theta now what's theta in this case in
the case I've said one it's zero right
I'm on the real axis sorry I should say
I want the positive real axis right so I
don't need to go anywhere to fish my
angle all right so all right cause zero
plus I sine zero okay all right now just
before I move off right like obviously
this is true because quad 0 is 1 and
sine zero is zero so the imaginary
component to zero there's the real
component I already know about okay as
we've noticed already as well just as a
side note this is not a really way to
write this in modern form what's another
argument I could choose that would give
me the same point it's another angle I
could go all the way around
I could go 360 degrees or better in our
context two pi right so this could be
cos 2 pi plus I sine 2 pi I'm not gonna
write that though because it's not the
principal argument okay so this is a
better way to write minus PI to PI is
that what you think you yeah so yeah so
I can I could write it in however where
like I'd go cos 2 pi plus I sine 2 pi I
can go cos 4 PI plus I sine 4 PI but
they're not very helpful ways to write
it
I can write in a more concise way
usually the principal argument okay
all right let's cut back up here okay
let's go to z2 right now again we've
chosen an easy example
what's the modulus 1 it's 2 1 ok what
angle am I Frank the positive real axis
90 degrees which is pliancy radians okay
so I've got cos PI to plus PI sine PI
don't you okay
now by the way just to save ourselves a
little bit of trouble and so I don't
keep asking you this okay the modulus
for every single one of these particular
points they're all one okay the plural
of modulus is moduli okay just like um
what's it like radius of radii okay not
radius so the budget for all of these
are one so I'm just going to save myself
a bit of time and I'm gonna write that
I'm gonna write that for all of these
other ones all right okay do you have a
question or yeah no if we go away from
here and measure across our angle what's
our argument for z3 what is arg of Zed 3
I've got to go all the way around 180
degrees or PI radians okay so I'm gonna
get cos pi plus I sine pun okay now
again we can verify this by what we know
of trig yeah coz coz pie that's halfway
along the closed curve right half way
along so you started one and you come
down to negative one
what about the imaginary part what's
sine pi it's zero because again it's
halfway along the sine curve and halfway
is bennett at zero so that works last
one
be careful because I want to try and
preserve the principle argument here
it's gonna be cos minus PI on to because
I'm gonna go measure this way which is
negative see
okay now I am going to write it okay I'm
gonna write both for this particular
game because actually very useful to me
I'm gonna write it but I hope you can
see cause three these are the same
complex number but only the first one
uses the principle argument
so this one is generally preferred okay
now let's think about this right imagine
now that you don't know this black
representation you don't know that you
could write it as one or I or minus I 1
et cetera all you know is this blue
Morag form okay how would you describe
what operation is getting you from one
number to the next okay for instance the
moduli they're all staying the same so
nothing interesting is happening there
okay that's fine what about the
arguments are not the angles what's
happening each time that's right I mean
we noticed this before it's rotation
right but for here to here I add PI to
nothing for here to here I add PI to and
from here to here I add PI or two just
so that we have unambiguous form that's
all really yeah because otherwise it's
like which which way would you like to
write the number you know we read out
which famously weird out if we have
different representations for the same
number you know it just it just doesn't
fit with us right we want to have things
that are unambiguous right so this is a
way of trying different all right so
just to rewind right as I transition
around the circle as I rotate this way
the moduli have stayed the same but the
angles are adding and adding UK with
that idea